success isn't owned it's rented and the  rent is due every single day delight  yourself in the Lord and He will give  you the desires of your heart  my family has been instrumental in the  development of Who I am without my mom  dad and brothers said I would not be the  man I am today  this decision will always be a  reflection of what they've taught me in  life I'll never forget the sacrifice of  the teachers parents friends and  volunteers my community means everything  to me  my coaches of helping me realize my  potential encouraged me to not just be  good but strive to be the best I am  forever grateful  at the end of the day  this is a decision that I can only make  everyone says to go to the place that is  best for you and I know what's best for  me  here I Camela  fight on